you saw the footage of what happened
with George Froy you're in this world
what do you think about what Derek Owen
did himself this was a travesty for the
entire country my heart breaks for the
Floyd family for what happened that was
awful there's nothing you can show me
that would justify that action nobody
dislikes a bad cop more than a good cop
the show live PD is gonna be taken down
it was a shock to me it was the number
one cable TV show for a long time this
rioted booty and what's going on
Washington this nonsense has to stop
these same people that are out
protesting right now they don't have the
balls to come out and do this job
there's been bad leadership and law
enforcement that has created distrust
what does the word be fun the police
mean to you most of people out there
asking to be fun police have no concept
of what they're talking about police
across this country have been defunded
even though the problem is its weak
leadership decades of piss-poor
leadership
so yesterday I sent a tweet out saying
cops TV show canceled after 32 years
Lego halted City police station a-any
pulled live PD from schedule and now
they're talking about paw patrol and I
have two boys and they love paw patrol
and I said listen why don't we have
somebody come and be a guest from life
PD and then Josh our friend contacted
the 24th sheriff of Pinal County in
Arizona sheriff Marco lamb who is one of
the stars on the show life PD that gives
2.1 million
regular viewers and this show has said I
believe nearly 300 episodes 298 episodes
he runs a 39 million dollar budget which
covers all aspects of the sheriff's
office I think roughly 650 employees the
size of Connecticut this county where
he's at is the size of Connecticut with
that being said sheriff Mark lamb thank
you so much for being a guest on by
attainment Thank You Patrick thanks for
having me it's great to have you so you
know obviously the events the tragic
events that happened a couple weeks ago
with the video going viral and then
you're seeing the four cops and the
handling of it and it in few
and everybody to the point where media
picked it up and it was riots protesting
that happens a couple weeks ago when did
you kind of get the news that would what
is going on today the show live PD is
gonna be taken down I literally was on a
zoom call Tuesday night we were talking
about wanted it actually that lipo deny
he wanted and we just as soon live he
was gonna be on the next night I was out
with some congressmen down on the south
end of our county looking at some border
issues and had about four messages when
I got out and through with the
congressman and and every one of them
was about how live PD was canceled so it
was a shock to me obviously I'm
disappointed because I think we need
more we need some positive police stuff
now more than ever but you know I'm not
on that and I don't know what all the
reasons are why they did that so also
there wasn't an explanation they didn't
explain what the reason it was to cancel
the show now I don't I didn't get an
explanation I don't know if anybody else
did I think they just a and he just
decided to move that direction so so I
am looking around for different kind of
stories on one cause that some of them
are bringing out the fact that the
events that took place in Texas March
28th 2019 would have your Ambler or that
was stopped in Texas for failing to dim
his headlights in March and then later
on held down and tasered four times
while a crew from life PD filmed it and
an amber died in custody footage of the
encounter never aired and was destroyed
and later on Dan Abrams another host of
life PD appear of yours says you regress
the footage and yesterday the network
made a statement yesterday or two days
ago they made the statement this is a
critical time in our nation's history
and we have made the decision to cease
production on live PD going forward we
will determine if there is a clear
pathway to tell the stories of both the
community and the police officers whose
role is to serve them and with that we
will be meeting with the community and
civil rights leaders as well as police
departments now for people that are out
there AME is owned by Disney and it's
not like it's a small
operation years the number one cable
show for quite a long time so it was
there some speculation that this is one
of the reasons why they said if this is
what's going on folks are coming out
saying because of that we should cancel
the entire show or do you think it was
more media driving the division of
America today if you were to speculate
yourself is there any direction you go
yourself
you know there's I think there's a lot
to play here I think everybody
unfortunately we're making decisions
rash decisions right now I think we
always used to call this when I was a
deputy or officer back at my other
agency we called it operation a jerk
reaction and I think this canceled
culture this virtue shaming that
probably contributed into it to a
certain point I don't know how much that
case out in Texas I hadn't even heard of
that case until Tuesday night they
finally heard about that case and that
standard though this is they destroy
they get rid of all their footage after
like 30 days so unless an attorney
requests that footage I think this falls
more on that side you know the
prosecutor whoever it is that was due in
that case the day and requests that
footage you can't hold a private company
responsible for that they have a policy
and a procedure in place and they just
kept following that so it's sad that the
footage was lost I'm sorry that somebody
lost their life but my heart goes out to
that family but it's it's unfortunate I
don't know that life PD is to blame for
that you know you also have the downturn
in the economy there has been a real
impact to the entertainment industry as
far as people being able to advertise
companies going under and I think that's
affected to a large part that the
entertainment industry and who knows may
they had just recently signed a big huge
tree extension to the contract with my
PD I think was 180 episodes more so
maybe that played a part I don't know I
think there's a lot of factors in it I'm
disappointed that it was actually
canceled but I have a I have a belief
that somebody somewhere is gonna want to
pick that show up it was the number one
cable TV show for a long time every
South Friday and Saturday night coming
in at number one so and there are a lot
of upset people
this country that this show is no longer
on I know a lot of people would only
have cable for live TV so it's gonna be
interesting to see what happens in the
future but I am disappointed like
everybody else now let me ask you this
question growing up you know I grew up
to cops is what I grew up and I lived in
LA and I grew up watching you know cops
you know bad boys bad boys would you
know you would watch the show and you
you know was entertaining seeing two
different stories of it what are the
positive and the negatives of having
shows like life PD or cops on TV I think
the positive in the negative or the same
it shows what the job is
and so it shows that what we do and it's
not always glamorous and it always it
doesn't always it doesn't always look
great it we don't like when we go out
and arrest somebody that's not what we
want to do like we don't set out for the
day and say hey I want to arrest
everybody
we actually just want to go out and keep
the peace and that becomes an
unfortunate side of our job and we have
to actually take somebody to jail for
their actions I think that's what people
forget a lot of times is the reason
we're there at that call is because
somebody broke the law and then we have
in many cases and victim and we have a
responsibility to act on that so those
things are shown in a good you see that
our side of it you see the law
enforcement piece of it you see the good
things we do you see how we handle these
cases but at the same time we're
actually showing you how we handle these
cases and sometimes that can be a
negative as well people don't don't
understand it they may not agree with it
and right now we're in a crazy world I
don't know somebody flipped it upside
down and we're only listening to the 510
percent of the people out there that
have a loud voice on the bullhorn right
now but I'm going to tell you right now
the majority of people across this
country are not feeling the same way
there's polls that show that they did
some polls back at a university it
showed that there was over 70 percent
approval rating for law enforcement
brewery either they somewhat were
somewhat or very satisfied with law
enforcement and that was that was
amongst different races that was amongst
college graduates actually be the rate
was higher for college graduates than it
was for non college
so the narrative that police are not
doing a good job is not true it's just
what's loud and it's what the media
unfortunately is pushing and they're
throwing gas on the fire that's
unfortunate
well let me ask you this you you saw the
footage of what happened with George
Floyd you're in this world you're
somebody that you know like when you
have analysts and sports and you're
watching an NBA game you got Shaq
Barkley Kenny Smith and they're saying
Ernie hey you know if I was them this is
what I would do if I wasn't because
that's their world they're in the world
of basketball if you looked at it from
the analyst standpoint what do you think
about what Derrick Chauvin did himself
having as me on George Floyd for eight
minutes and I believe 46 seconds it was
awful it was awful I couldn't hardly I
couldn't watch it I still don't know if
I would watch the video all the way
through and then I've been you know I
can hardly watch I was watching Hannity
a few days later and they were bringing
up some great points but I just couldn't
watch it anymore
this was a travesty nobody dislikes a
bad cop more than a good cop this was a
travesty for the entire country and this
was actually something where the entire
country was on the same page we all
thought this was awful and then I think
that with what we've seen with the
rioting and the looting I think we've
we've lost the opportunity or at least
we've made it very difficult to really
to really take that where the whole
country was on the same page and we lost
that opportunity and now it's once again
law enforcement we're trying to recover
that and we're trying to get back to the
table with everybody and and reassure
everybody that that is such a small
percentage in law enforcement it's
unfortunate that it exists but I don't
care what industry you're in there are
bad people in every industry no question
we do the best we can to weed those
people out I would hope that everybody
would give us the opportunity to get
back to the table and this route this
rioted moving and what's going on in
Washington this nonsense has to stop
because it is not helping the narrative
it's not helping
what these people want to stand for for
those who want to really address the
issues this this the riotous behavior
does not help
we had a comedian here in our community
where we met with community leaders we
got right to work we didn't just talk
about it we pulled him in and we had a
four-hour conversation where we just
talked heart-to-heart and I let them
vent and I listened and I really got a
better perspective of a lot of things
and then we also took a lot of takeaways
on what we can do better in our agency
that's what you should be seeing across
this country that's the type of dialogue
honestly my my heart breaks for the
Floyd family for what happened that was
awful but it's also awful what's been
going on since then and it needs to stop
what is the right protocol in a
situation like that and how are the four
officers held accountable you have the
the 17 year old who's recording it and
you know holding the cops accountable
and then you have the four so when
you're saying it's awful what is the
proper protocol in that situation
because we're not in that world you know
what I don't like to armchair
quarterback that putting a knee in the
back and in the neck is not a pro is
that's not a technique or tactic we use
here and even if it was it's definitely
not something you use for eight and a
half minutes now everybody else standing
around they got charged well what about
the kid holding the camera that got
charged well look he stood around just
like the other cops there were other
people that just stood around so there
was a lot of people that should have
stepped in and tried to stop this
whether they would have got arrested or
not it's not doing the right thing a lot
of times and I'm not trying to cast
blame or take away from anything to
happen because what happened was awful
and you know what we're seeing that
those officers are gonna be held
responsible for it and they should and
we need to let the court of law just do
it much like we should have let the
court of law deal with George Floyd as
well it just was awful there's no
explanation for it there's nothing I can
say that will justify what and you can't
show me anything and this is just me
there's nothing you can show me that
would justify that action what you
should have done is once you had him in
cuffs and you got him under somewhat
control they should have just sat him up
crossed his legs he's got a hank of sine
he's not gonna be able to do anything or
put him in the back of the car
in both those times in those
neighborhoods wherever he's out you
wanted to scoop that guy up put him in
the back of the car and get out of a
volatile situation and this is a prime
example that situation turned volatile
like I said on that guy you know that
officer sat on George Floyd for eight
and a half minutes
it's it's so hard to watch and it's I
wish we could rewind it but we can tell
the youth that I work with all the time
we cannot change the past the only thing
we can do is work work for a better
future yeah that's good perspective to
know like because because all I want to
know is I want to know protocol you know
you you you if we there's something
obviously there's something wrong about
sitting on a man for 8 m8 I mean 8
minutes and 46 seconds and you got to
hang cuffs what is the right protocol so
that behavior is going to be judged in
the future of somebody else decides to
go that route you know the question I
had for today we were having lunch
yesterday and I said do you think these
events that are going on the last two
weeks I'm in a military I'm about to get
out when you're going through each
yessing you go through job offers and
there was a police a Fort Lauderdale
Police Department was hiring for $32,000
a yeren this is 1999 June and I'm
thinking about taking Fort Lauderdale PD
so then I come out and I'm thinking
about going to becoming an LAPD
obviously I told you I didn't have 60
speeding tickets and apparently they
don't like that but you know it's are
these events do you think these events
inspire more kids to say oh man I want
to go be a cop because I want to be a
good cop or do you think it gets people
to say dude I definitely don't want to
be a cop and I will never I never want
that job what do you think it does to
the application rate of new people
wanted to become police officers or get
into that world it kills it the hiring
was already hard enough the parameters
that are set for example let's take your
situation where you had 16 tickets you
know that immediate you probably would
have been amazing cop but because of
those 16 tickets we couldn't bring you
on and you would have had to put some
time in between you and the cop and then
and in that time
go get another job and you end up in a
different career now with the
legalization of marijuana and other
states there where it's legal in
Colorado well that kids smokes more than
20 times and comes Arizona and tries to
be a cop guess what you can't hire them
he's immediately disqualified for life
there are certain situations that
prescription pills those types of things
they disqualify you for life it's making
it hard emotionally - I know a lot of
good cops that are considering walking
away from the job right now because they
feel they're not appreciated I had a
girl just before I got on your show ten
minutes before I was messaging a gal
that I had met in her Starbucks who had
gone and got into the law enforcement
career she's nine weeks into her FTO
program and Shiah is questioning whether
or not she made the right choice and I
said you did you made the right choice
you know now's not the time gets tough
times get tough that's not when you bow
out this is what makes the truly major
person is is when it's tough and you
know we've we took on this job we knew
that was dangerous we knew there'd be
hard times and we all your time when you
leave this earth that's predetermined by
God already so the best thing you can do
is live like a lion that bold lift proud
live with your head held high and
there's nothing greater than living like
a warrior most people will never do that
we'll never know that and for all of you
who are in the law enforcement
profession I say hold the line don't let
this don't let these situations that
what we're going through right now and
discourage you and please don't let it
discourage you from applying to law
enforcement the pendulum will swing
swing back you know I was watching a
video today where these guys were
throwing stuff at vehicles and this guy
stops his car and he backs up the car he
gets out of the car and the first thing
is these little cowards say on their
video as they say somebody call the cops
so these people who are protesting and
throwing junk of people's cars the
second somebody stops from the lights
tries to hold them accountable the first
thing they go to is somebody call the
cops
automatic reaction I mean that's what
you think about you know I always say I
can't stand
cops pulling me over but you'll love it
when cops are there when they're you
know you call 911 and you know they're
there within five minutes you feel safer
when they're there so it all depends on
a situation you're in I also had a
friend of mine who was a cop and he told
me something one time he says Pat I said
tell me what it is to be a cop this guy
was a bodybuilder and this is years ago
20 years ago I got out of military we
met at Bally Total Fitness and I
couldn't become when he went to became
one I said let me ask you how is if we
becoming a cop because every time I saw
his chest getting bigger and he was
getting a little bit more you know a
power trip if you want to call it we go
to a nightclub you bring his gun with
him and you know he'd give it to the
security they put it out I'm like you
know there's there's something's
changing with this guy you know and
eventually bother we ended up being
fired five years later they fired him as
a cop he got terminated and he you know
had to go change his career do you also
see sometimes people who when they word
that badge and to have that gun it
sometimes gets to their head and if it
does how do you filter those people out
versus those who actually want to serve
I'm glad you asked that question because
every one of us knows a badge heavy cop
and there's a lot of guys that do it and
I'll tell you sometimes what creates
that is the things that we see the
things that we go through every day you
have to start really checking your
emotions at the door but that's also
counterintuitive to be in a good
community police officer you know when
you go and you see a baby that's been
raped that affects you when you go and
you see people domestic violence where a
husband and a wife have beat the crap
out of each other or a husband who's
who's the beat his wife within an inch
of her life that stuff takes a toll on
us now some guys handle it well and some
guys don't
and some people are bad Chevy I used to
say before I became a cop cops are two
types of people those who did the
beating up in high school and those who
got beat up in high school either way
they typically have an axe to grind and
that's unfortunate and we as
administrators have to do a our job is
hard to try to weed those types of
people out to really get the right
people for the job
now what this when I had my community
meeting the other day they said Sheriff
you've got to be you've got to get rid
of the bad officers and I said I can't
it's not
it is hard as hell to fire a bad cop I
have to put paper on this guy over and
over and over again and then you fire
them and they get their job back because
we have strong unions that support it
now on the other hand having said that I
want to also say something on behalf of
the officers and the line level guys the
reason they've unionized and the reason
why we have an officer's bill of rights
here in Arizona is because of the
distrust that exists between them and
bad administration's there has been bad
leadership in law enforcement that is
created distrust within the air own
agencies with the line level guys that
have been treated Mis fairly and that's
why you have an officers Bill of Rights
well that same thing also it makes it
difficult for me to weed out the guys
that or any other administrator to weed
out the ones that we know could be bad
heavy or are on a collision course with
something like this so this is something
we deal with every day we're not
ignorant to it but these are some of the
challenges we face and it was great to
be able to explain that to some of our
community members because they didn't
know that they didn't understand that
piece of it and so in that open
conversation the other night they were
able to talk to us and we were able to
talk to them about some of the protocols
in place and different things that that
contribute to this and we would love
more than anything to have every call go
exactly perfect but it's just
unfortunate it doesn't but the reality
is the statistics show that we respond
to 54 million plus calls in this country
every year as law enforcement and a very
very very small percentage don't go
right and it's unfortunate and most
times that might cost somebody their
life but this is a hard job and if it
was if it was easy more people would be
out doing it and I mean I'd be saying
people that are out protesting right now
forgive my they don't have the balls to
come out and do this job most of them so
and I'm not talking about the peaceful
process I'm talking about the people
doing the rioting and the looting they
don't have the guts to come out and do
this job or the courage come out and do
this job and now there's
Nino's we've seen you know what we saw
I'm gonna go back to it was terrible and
I think every law enforcement agency
across this country is reevaluating
their own agencies to make sure this
doesn't happen at our agencies and and
we're doing the work already you don't
need to go out and tear everything up
it's not necessary yeah it's gonna get
out of control you're seeing a
Christopher Columbus statue and then
Cuomo comes out and he says that was not
the right move because he had a very big
effect on the Italian community and we
can't be doing that and even Cuomo who's
somebody who is supporting the
protesters took that position saying
he's not comfortable with that
you know the badge heavy party were
talking about give a rare example either
those who were bullies and those who
were bullied chose to become cops and
you don't know how to control the bad
Chevy folks
I had a challenge with you know we were
having this debate with a group of
people and we're talking about teachers
and I said tell me the best teacher you
ever had my teacher till today miss st.
Claire I joined your army because this
lady she's for 11
she was my health and guidance teacher
she inspired me I want to became a
soldier after high school had a 1.8 GPA
but she changed my life mr. woods
mrs. Sinclair there's a list of them
till today we write letters to each
other
but the concept of tenure ok the concept
of tenure now you have where a teacher
goes in does their tenure they can't get
fired they don't have to do a good job
it's not like it's the private market
where you don't do your party get
negative reviews you get a term entity
to get fire you're worried about what if
I don't perform how much of that also
applies to the world you're in and what
can change the whole cops more
accountable moving forward you know that
a lot of it applies now there's certain
states I know there's sheriffs and let's
say Missouri North Carolina these they
can fire a police officer at will you
know for for anything and that creates a
tough spot sometimes because people you
if you decide you don't like a guy just
for personal differences you can fire
the guy and it's not fair to him and his
family but at the same time they can
fire somebody that they see is a bad cop
too and the other thing that we don't
have in place out here that some people
are wanting as a reform is
some type of database that where a guy
if a guy gets let go from another agency
we can look in and find out about that
everybody's been burnt by that where you
hire a guy and you think he's going to
be good and the previous agency didn't
tell you about all the problems he had
because nobody didn't document or
citizens who would call you and complain
but they didn't actually follow through
with a full-on complaint so you know
there's no paperwork on that and then
what happens is an agency like mine
might pick up somebody that's carrying a
bunch of baggage that we hit open so I
think there's ways that you can do this
database and I don't know how accessible
you make that database but a database at
least for people hiring that we can see
whether that guy's had some previous
issues you maybe have to you know you're
gonna have to sit down with some of
these unions and talk to ways reach out
to them and see what they what ideas
they have to weed some of these guys out
give us some more flexibility there
without losing the trust of our line
level guys because that's the last thing
I want to do is lose the trust of my
dental as well so there's a lot of tough
conversations that need to be had on all
sides of our offense and on all sides of
the table and we've got to do it and
we've got to start now and hopefully we
can get to where it we make this better
it's not going to be overnight though
like that's be stinks take time III
agree I just I just would love to see
how that dialogue is gonna take place
because the biggest thing would be you
have two sides I run an insurance
company 15,000 agents and have folks who
are calling me telling me Pat how can
you you know not see it that this is how
how can he not see then the other side
gives their site but if both sides they
have some reasonable arguments on both
ends if progress is made on both sides
to make some kind of a form of being
held accountable I think Trust would go
up you know Trust goes up peace comes
right afterwards but then even that
leads me to different topic here's how
big of a role you think media is playing
right now in dividing America and
turning you know issues that are
important but turning them into a way to
make sure they divide so we get more
I bought watching media how do you view
media yourself the media is almost there
I don't want to say they're fully
responsible but they should they need to
shoulder the brunt of what's going on
here
they have instilled fear into the
American public
they were doing it through the
coronavirus situation and now they're
doing it here and the politics is so
blatant it's not even funny if you can't
see the politics and the underlying
agendas in what's going on here then to
any of your viewers I challenge you to
please open your eyes and start to look
at what's going on look at the things
that are happening or the things that
were swept under the table during the
last three four months when we went from
coronavirus and then we rolled into this
this situation here the media has to
stop and still in fear of the people and
they're giving they're making the
American public think that this is the
majority that you're hearing from out on
the streets and it is not and I think
you're gonna start to see a lot more
pushback from the average American
citizen they're trying to undo our
president which is shameful that people
would hate this country and freedom so
much to undo a president look I didn't I
didn't appreciate the president that you
know President Obama didn't I didn't
agree with hardly anything I didn't
think he was a good president at all and
I think it's showing through now but at
the same time I didn't go out and raise
hell because of it I did it the way I
did it is I decided to run for sheriff I
decided to get politically active to be
able to change my country I didn't do it
the wrong way and what we need is media
that starts to go back to true
journalism to report the facts and to
stop instilling fear into the parts of
the American public so I don't like to
cache shame but shame on the media
they've done a terrible job it's it's a
travesty and what they're doing to
divide to get eyeballs the whole
divide-and-conquer model is fine if it
comes out to other areas but the
divide-and-conquer nation to get more my
eyeballs is as divisive as it can get
the war defunding defund the police you
hear they
defund the police defund the police
defund the police while I worked in
Camden a city outside of Philadelphia
17,000 people living there but Philly's
got one point seven million people they
used to have four employer
four cops in Camden but they decided to
get away and it's more a local militia
and they have a certain system that
they're using what does the word defund
the police mean to you what is your
interpretation of the request that's
being made from the protesters of
defunding the police it's ludicrous and
it's a it's a talking point for people
who hate this country who dislike our
president and they've put it in these
hearts of these people most of people
out there asking to defund police have
no concept of what they're talking about
you're talking about the police across
this country have been defunded you
wonder what the problem is and I did a
video about this and it's been up to
like 1.5 million views it's weak
leadership the problems where you have
issues with law enforcement have plenty
like Chicago Detroit Minneapolis places
that have decades of piss-poor
leadership people who have been who have
gotten away from from protecting their
communities they use politics they are
racing rate they divide races and and
it's predominantly from the left
look I don't typically get into politics
left or right I try to stay away from
that but there's no question if you
can't look and look at all these cities
that are struggling with their
relationships with law enforcement
they're almost always been over been run
but by decades 100% run by people from
the Democrat Party and their solution is
instead of taking responsibility for
their failures now they say well let's
defund the police and they're talking
about giving more money to programs
they're already blowing money on
programs that aren't working and that
you know in many of these places they
need to be actually putting more police
officers in place defunding the police
and taking police officers on the
streets are going to kill these
communities that are most affected by
what that what these people are out
protesting for they are gonna this will
kill these communities less police will
only increase crime
it'll only increase
you're gonna have neighborhoods that
people will not want to go to they will
become literal war zones it's it's just
it's honestly it's ludicrous what we
need to do is we need to make sure that
our police are appropriately funded we
need to make sure that we have school
resource officers back in school we need
more money for if for police programs
that we can go out into the community I
have a youth redirection program I have
to fund that with my charity or with
Rico funds because I don't have the
funding for it in my in my budget and
you know what I've got a hundred kids
come through that program and instead of
being charged and going through the
court system they were able to they were
able to wipe their slate clean and out
of those hundred kids that have gone
through zero have reoffended its
programs like that are that are gonna
change our communities and the money
that we should be dedicated should go to
those programs um so we need just bet we
need to do a better job on our own but
defunding the police is just it's
honestly and even in this meeting I'll
end it with this with this question but
even in the meeting I did with our
community members the other day I said
what do you guys think about beef on
police there wasn't a single person in
that room who thought that was that was
smart or who thought that was a
legitimate answer to the issues what
they all asked for was reform and on the
and one thing I said is you have to be
careful in this country not to throw a
blanket of reform on in the entire
police in every agency across this
country because a lot of us are doing it
right we do have shaitaan' communities
and we do have excellent community
relations so you can't just throw a
blanket on every police force in this
nation because the majority of us are
doing it right it's interesting you say
that because the question that comes to
my mind is okay let's just say defunding
police is taking a portion of the money
here and invest and get into the
community kind of like what mayor
Garcetti is saying we're taking 150
million dollars outside of a you know
the the
police department in LA and we're going
to put it into the communities and
that's what we're going to be doing the
first thing I think about is how long
does it take to change a community or an
individual here's a 1.8 GPA kid at
you're 18 years old knucklehead if you
gave me a million dollars I'd probably
end up in prison or I'd be in Vegas
doing the dumbest things for span of a
month until I ran out of money because
I'm not capable to be given a million
dollars right with gradual change of
shifting working and proving myself then
I go from somebody about all my friends
parents they don't want me to be around
now those parents are calling me telling
me can you call my son please can you
call my kid and talk to them
how long does gradual change really take
place in a community it takes time I
think you're a generation away I think
that you start with your youth now I
think you've got to start with your
youth you know I had theirs as you get
older 40 50 years old there's things
that I'm proud I'm never gonna change
your mind on certain things yeah you
know and you've got things that are
ingrained in you and we can do the best
we can to hopefully offset that and
maybe but with the youth we actually
have a shot we can actually really
because that's what the left's doing
they're trying to indoctrinate this
youth the people with this again de that
hate America and that want to take away
your freedom they've understood that and
they've worked for generates - to
recondition the minds of our youth we
need to get back to instilling good
American principles and values and the
things that this country was built on we
need to start that with our youth and
hopefully by the time they have kids
that we have in that generation we've
gotten back to where we need to be but I
honestly believe it's going to take a
generation to fix it well that's a good
to know when you say generation and it
starts with the youth it's always
started with the youth and I think about
it with myself on how it happened
somebody got a hold of me early and he
believed in me and she believed in me
and gradually poured into me and
encouraged me to change and then I
became a different man that you would
have recognized from 25 to 18 and a
positive progress takes place and I
think it does take some time for that to
become a reality thank you so much for
taking it
and I'm assuming I'm speculating that's
somebody out there is probably gonna
contact you guys to get that show back
on life PD because it is very hard to
get 2 point 1 million viewers of people
that want to watch the show and even
more than that there's a form of
accountability if we can see what it
would you guys do as a cop if we can
have which as sheriff if if we can
actually see the handling of it you are
is essentially being held accountable so
if I'm a betting man I'm betting
someone's going to be interested on the
show here soon
sheriff lamb where can people find you
yes after this show people may be may or
may not like me but if you like me come
to sheriff lab you can I am running for
office again this year it's unfortunate
that I got to do it every four years but
I really do love America
I'm a patriot at heart I'm a god-fearing
man I love my communities I work hard
every day to it's to put community
programs in place to avoid situations
like what we saw in Minneapolis I really
work hard to be out in the community you
see that I'm the sheriff I put on the
best in the badge and I go out and I
work with my guys I believe in
leadership by example and I think that
America needs more strong leaders and we
need people that will accept
responsibility for their failures and
that will work hard to make the changes
and when they do that's true leadership
that's what we're lacking in these
country that's what we're lacking from
these people these mayor's they keep
wanting to put the blame back on the
police officers but they're really at
fault for their failures over the last
several years that's why people are
moving out in those states and come in
to places like Arizona because it's a
great place to live so hopefully people
will go check me out so Frank calm I
also have a charity American Sheriff Pat
org we just try to do good in our
community so thank you every day Pat for
Thank You Pat for having me on today to
to talk about these things I appreciate
you I know your job is a tough job it's
not an easy job and it's probably ten
times tougher today so thank you for
your service and thank you for being a
guest on body tainment thank you god
bless god bless you as well thank you
obviously this is a very sensitive topic
not everybody has answers too and I'm
trying to figure out what is the right
approach to this what do you do to make
it better for cops to be held
accountable what are you do for the
citizens to gain trust back with police
what does the police need to do I mean
it's a very very complex situation so I
want to hear your thoughts about today's
interview with sheriff lamb and I did an
interview in the past with Bernard Kerik
the former commissioner of NYPD during
the time you know he cleaned the streets
of New York crime went down him and Rudy
Giuliani worked very closely together
and we went through the game plan of how
they did that in the city of New York so
if you have a watch that interview click
over here to watch that interview with
Bernard Kerik and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]